two months ago in late august people in
new mexico noticed hundreds of migratory
birds that had fallen dead
right out of the sky within a few weeks
the numbers had expanded to
thousands of birds across other states
including colorado
arizona texas and nebraska scientists
have been struggling for an explanation
as they look to protect birds from
other threats barry peterson reports
it's early morning on colorado's bar
lake north of denver
where the bird conservancy of the
rockies is located
meredith mcburney who does bird banding
for the conservancy
is on the hunt for birds captured in her
nets
so what do you have here okay we have a
little
we have a little sparrow that has flown
into the net
and we're gonna take him out and we'll
put him in a bag why don't you hold the
bag
okay okay just hold it now
he was flying this way he was looking
into the bushes
and he flew into this very fine
net and i'm going to
get him out banding helps track
migration
a migration this year marked by a
massive die-off across
several western states new mexico was
hard hit
as university of new mexico phd student
jenna mccullough
and fellow student nick vinsegara
discovered
it was somber and we were
picking up birds very quietly in our own
respective bags and
generally the only things we were saying
was incredulous at
how many birds were there some experts
blame an early september cold snap
when temperatures dropped 60 degrees in
a single day
killing off insects there are no flying
insects
there's no food for the birds to eat and
they are more likely to
succumb to starvation scott rasheed runs
the colorado avian
research and rehabilitation institute he
thinks
smoke and ash from unprecedented forest
fires
across the west may also be a factor
outside for all the ash coming out of
the sky and
looking at these poor birds and thinking
about how small their lungs are
to me my guess is that they just they
can't breathe anymore
this is another migratory sparrow arvind
punjabi
is the bird conservancy's avian
conservation scientist
take a look and tell me what you're
seeing yeah let's see
i see some western grebes out there
and of course the american white
pelicans there's some canada geese
not surprisingly he worries about next
spring
when birds migrate back to burned out
areas some birds nest
in the same forest some in the same tree
i mean the swaths of burned-out trees is
going to be extraordinary this year
right so you've got to expect there's
going to be some significant
population declines because they just
can't find where they used to live
that's right because the birds do still
come back to those areas
but they may not be surviving or
reproducing well in those areas anymore
and i think after we see that because
after a few more
years after the fire they're no longer
there so they'll abandon
that area eventually they'll die off
punjabi co-authored a study detailing a
30 decline of american birds
in the last five decades due to things
like
habitat loss
one way to prevent billions of bird
deaths keep pet cats inside
so they don't kill birds it takes a
cultural change and it
takes starting them young to keep them
indoors and keep them happy
but indoor cats live a longer life they
have fewer diseases than parasites
so you know in the end it's a win-win
for the cats and the environment
back at the bird conservancy i'll
measure the leg
meredith mcburney is checking size and
weight
and then banding the birds and this bird
now has its band for life
then gets a little help from her newest
assistant
put your hands together like this now
you have a very important job as i say
to the young children
do nothing okay
and then if you roll him into one hand
or the other so he's right side up
yep
and away he goes yep
that was really fun
[Laughter]
i love it i'll just stay here all day
and do the bird release can i get that
job
yes you can have that job it's sad to
think
of the long-term decline of birds just
watch
what birds mean to the children who
visit the conservancy
to see to touch and to find in these
tiny creatures nature's absolute wonder
for cbs this morning saturday barry
peterson
barrow lake colorado um well that was
just fantastic
yeah and important i take that job
i really all you have to do is just stay
yeah as you said
just roll the roll i can manage but
important yes
we can we laugh at barry's reaction
because he's such a natural and so great
about it but it's an important story too